and USA Today reports Equifax had two
months to prevent its massive data
breach but failed to install a software
fix cybersecurity experts say a patch
for the flaw was issued in March
hackers didn't start stealing that
sensitive information from Equifax from
up to a hundred and forty three million
Americans until May Anna Warner's at a
cybersecurity summit in New York she
spoke with a former Equifax employee who
raised questions about the company's
practices and a good morning good
morning well behind me you can see this
cybersecurity conference getting
underway and the number one topic of
conversation here is the Equifax breach
how did it happen and why didn't the
company spot the problem earlier
something was missed
Chris madman says he expects a company
like Equifax to do a good job securing
its computer systems it definitely
worries me it's not something that
anyone should take lightly Mad Men is
vice-president of the Apache Software
Foundation the organization behind
Apache struts a popular program used by
Equifax for building websites in March
his group discovered a bug that let
hackers take control of computers
running the software a fix was issued
the same day if you don't apply you know
those security patches and things like
that you basically willfully ignore them
or whatever well then you're subject to
sort of the outcome of what could happen
from that you're vulnerable it's unclear
why Equifax may have left its computers
unprotected for months on Thursday the
Federal Trade Commission took the
unusual step of confirming it is
investigating how hackers access
sensitive data on roughly 143 million
Americans
Monisha methought associate director of
the FTC's privacy and Protection
Division says the agency has sued about
60 companies that didn't take reasonable
steps to protect private information in
many cases we found that companies had
simple passwords to letter passwords
they didn't update their antivirus or
software or their firewalls showing
Frick's was a lead information analyst
at Equifax he says people in his
department shared unmasked Social
Security numbers to company offices
overseas this is
people's personal informations their
socials their date of births their
addresses what's being sent basically a
third world country after nearly eight
years with the company Frick's was fired
in 2015 in a dispute over his overtime
pay he later sued you're basically a
commodity your informations a commodity
now we asked Equifax for response to
shaun Phrixus allegations we have not
heard back the company did settle that
lawsuit with him paying him thirty five
thousand dollars with no admission of
wrongdoing
Equifax also did not respond to
additional questions about that software
question and any more details on the
breach itself Gail a lot of people need
to check their credit reports thank you
very much Anna